work from home is incredibly challenging
building culture remotely is impossible
it's very hard attention is the number
one asset the theme of this podcast is
about rapid response and you are like
the epitome of the person who runs to
the new with Great Gusto and energy I'm
curious what rapid response means to you
and what you're responding to now I I
think it means opportunity I think it
means curiosity I think it means truth
you know I'm fascinated by people's
inability to get out of no culture you
know to put their head in the I'm
fascinated by putting your head in the
sand it's what led me to discovering
emotional intelligence you know for
years I was a public figure speaking of
like here's an opportunity here's an
opportunity here's an opportunity I
would wonder why people close to me let
alone the general audience wouldn't act
on it and it led me to realizing that
people insecure or lack self-esteem or
or really struggle with people's
judgment or have these poor
relationships with themselves you know
it's funny when you speak about rapid
response I think it means someone who
lacks fear you know because the nature
of running fast to something new is
potentially scary you may fail you may
waste your time you may get burnt um but
for me it's it's subconscious it's all I
really know and and that's not a bad
thing to to waste your time I mean
you're not really wasting your time well
that's that's my point like so many my
friends are like you spent 30 hours
digging into that hypothesis your time
has become so valuable why are you doing
that I'm like because if I write once
every 45 times it fully pays for
everything else I think people are
incredibly good at Academia but not good
at actual life and so um you know I
don't to your point I don't see it as
waste of times things I've learned going
down rabbit holes became data points in
context to other moments of going down
rabbit holes that allowed me to either
bail early pattern recognition or triple
down in an opportunity and so you know
I'm uh I really I really don't know how
a CEO or entrepreneur um sees the world
in any other way I feel like that's
their responsibility I'm very empathetic
to why a CFO or or other Executives in
business context don't do it um but you
know I think it's funny the the whole
framework of this makes me think about
Comfort fear self-esteem insecurity
those are the things that pop up in my
mind when I hear it you've got a new
book project yes day trading attention
you've done six business books before
this right so why was this a rabbit hole
that you decided to go down it's the
biggest conversation I see that's
Universal whether you're a nonprofit
whether you're running for mayor whether
you are running a small small business
whether you're the CEO of a big company
a Creator an
influencer everyone is trying to figure
out how to create
demand yeah right yeah like everyone's
you know when I when I say everyone's
selling something I don't see that as a
negative I mean everyone's trying to
communicate Something That Matters to
them I think selling is very good when
you believe in what you're selling I
think if you're part of a nonprofit
curing a disease that is incredibly good
selling and I also don't begrudge
someone who's trying to sell lollipops I
did that in sixth grade like
everything's allowed as long as you're
doing it the right way and so um I
believe that the world of marketing and
communication has made a very aggressive
turn and I think people are struggling
and wasting money on traditional and
digital you know I don't think you know
I don't think this is a digital versus
traditional thing I think that I know
because I liveit it every day you can
waste an ungodly amount of money on
influencers on Facebook on Instagram on
Tik Tok on Spotify um just as easily as
you can in a newspaper or billboard or
radio yeah and so I think the craft of
being great at storytelling running ads
creating content for the modern internet
being prepared for the arvr world of the
next
decade the framework that makes sense to
me is day trading attention meaning
whether it's a Super Bowl ad which I
think is underpriced for Fortune 500 or
it's a carousel ad
on you know Instagram or LinkedIn or
it's an emerging influencer on Tik Tok
to make content for your local car wash
business or SAS business that selling to
Fortune 500 companies on LinkedIn I
think the nuances of communication and
marketing have become so profoundly
challenging that most people are really
struggling and I'm very fortunate to be
sitting in the eye of the storm and I
always get most excited when I think I'm
writing a book that is going to lead to
tens of thousands of emails of thank you
and I've written a couple of those and I
know what they feel like versus the
other ones I've written that have less
thank yous I think this one's going to
be a big one I think it's a follow-up to
jab jab jab right hook which was a big
book that I wrote in 2013 that said this
is how you do content on social media
this one is probably the nerdiest book
I've ever written it's like
even I'm a little worried that it may
not be as commercially successful
because it is a little text Booky on the
flip side that's what might make it very
commercially successful so it's
I definitely pushed myself to go further
into like going behind the the cloak of
like what I do for a living what we do
for a living why a lot of things work
for me I'm proud of that I what what I
mean by that is someone said something
to me six or seven years ago that really
felt nice it was like I remember it hit
me right in my chest she didn't know me
very well she hung out in this business
meeting and then went out it and she
said you're incredibly intellectually
generous and I uh I was very flattered
by that and I feel like this book is
intellectually generous I feel like I'm
writing a book of The Secret Sauce that
makes most my stuff work and I'm excited
that that people are going to take that
baton and be able to build for
themselves and and if I'm hearing I mean
there's so many ways to reach people now
so many more ways than ever and it
sounds like you're saying that people
feel like oh I have to cover all the
bases as opposed to looking at each one
of as a Marketplace and figuring out
what the right opportunity is for you
for your brand for your message at that
moment period that that if you're if
you're like there's just so many
examples I can give if you are a
florist Instagram feels incredibly
natural because a lot of people are
there but it's also hard right now the
supply and demand of attention on
Instagram makes it challenging yeah
meanwhile I know the cliche the average
the typical florist is not thinking
about link LinkedIn meanwhile LinkedIn
is acting like Facebook in 2015 where on
LinkedIn if you post about floral
arrangements or why you're a good option
for a corporate floral or just a one-off
Valentine's Day thing it is more likely
that you will get organic reach on
LinkedIn than than Instagram I know that
99.9% of the people listening to this
podcast would not believe that to be
true but I know it to be true and
there's a hundred other things I'm
thinking about or know to be true and so
I'm going to use this book to lay that
out but also get people into the right
mindset which is there's attention and
there's filling that attention this
podcast MH everyone who listens to it is
going to listen to me right now the
variable of success for me and for you
is the words that come out of my mouth
the creative is the variable if I give
sharp insights if I give things that
bring people value they will feel better
towards me right so I think people are
thinking about all these social networks
as distribution but not thinking about
filling them with something that
actually works I believe that people are
mainly mailing in the content it's
inherently selfish look at me follow me
buy from me it's incredibly repetitive I
look at Brands and people every day
they're saying the same thing over and
over and over and over and over and over
that's grounded in selfishness and so I
don't think people are strategic I don't
think they understand the science around
the art of making a picture or video
work for you in YouTube YouTube Shorts
Facebook Facebook reals Facebook
Messenger WhatsApp WhatsApp Channel
Instagram Channel these are new things
broadcast channels the carousel ad the
video the real versus the regular post
LinkedIn versus Twitter Twitter versus
Snapchat Snapchat Discovery is where a
lot of creators should be making content
but they're only making it on Instagram
and Tik Tok so in a lot of ways the
books I've been writing for the last
almost two decades I feel like this is
the three one
course and um I'm really you probably
can sense it I'm really proud of it it
was really harder for me I always am so
ahead of things that I can just spit it
but this one I wanted to like re like
I'm dreaming of someone right now who's
listening to this post the book coming
out buying the book on Amazon and a week
later having like 40 highlights in it
and Pen like I know I'm up to something
the two books that have you know crush
it which really put me on the map right
you know that book and Jab jab jab right
hook they it acted differently than the
other books all my books have done well
they've all been New York Times bests
sellers but I'm still getting emails
about you know jab ja jab right hook
even though a lot of the content is not
as timely and so I felt like I needed to
do the updated version and the more
advanced version but still I've always
been the kind of Communicator that's
more of the average Joe so because I
record my books in audio form I don't
think I'm going to lose people in the
301 this and so I'm excited I'm really
excited about it so an attention
question to ask you about please
so uh Taylor Swift yes Travis Kelsey yes
have changed the NFL's business yes
without the NFL being a part of its plan
at all that's right like what is the
attention message from I know you're a
big NFL fan so like is there a message
in that yes of course there is it's
actually one of the biggest parts of the
book which is that everybody on Earth
underestimates pop culture what happened
with Taylor and Kelsey is they're
cross-pollinating their platforms so if
you're a mechanic in Detroit like I said
in this post on social you're not
thinking about hitting up the Thai
restaurant down the street to do a piece
of social media content I know that's
true today yet that's the kind of left
field post that will get people's
attention and so what I see there is
what do I think about pop culture I
think it's one of the most significant
currencies
on Earth what if you're lucky enough to
have an employee that works for you
that's first name is Travis and another
one that's first name is tayor like
literally you're a law firm Travis
Johnson Taylor Smith maybe they're both
guys because Taylor is obviously a name
that can go either way you can easily
use the micro moment of the infatuation
of our society to do something clever
and silly what people don't realize is
that little clever video on Instagram
that only got 90 views one of those 90
views is someone who's actually
considering to hire an attorney and they
actually like the fact that you were a
little silly and not buttoned up and you
made them feel more comfortable to reach
out to you to work with your Law Firm or
your dentist's place or your like I
people are very linear they don't
realize how big pop culture is and how
they can factor into their boring
business I had a I had a um gentleman
reach out to me who asked literally I
used a concrete cement business in one
of my analogies in a piece of content he
literally owned a asphalt business he
literally started to make Tik toks even
though he thought it was the wildest
craziest thing he'd ever heard and it
literally has doubled his business an
asphalt seller like guy that comes and
redo your driveway made a couple Tik
toks one went decent another one went
viral and literally if I recall properly
the email a business that was doing
$800,000 a year servicing a local area I
think he was in Wisconsin is now doing
2.5 Mill he he the tears were coming
through the
email but most people who are listening
to this podcast don't who are in a beab
or like a different kind of business are
not thinking how Tik Tok can work for
them right and pop culture doesn't
necessarily mean that you need to have a
your celebrity endorser correct you're
you're playing off of what the
conversations that are going on it's
like being good at a cocktail party
right think of this as your social media
marketing you go out tonight and it's a
fundraiser of your local local PTA or
the school or or it's the the banquet
for the high school basketball team are
you the kind of person that comes to
that event and you're enjoyable to talk
to and have a circle around you or are
you in the corner by yourself the
reality is being an introvert and not
being comfortable in that is incredibly
appropriate and awesome as a business
you'd like to think that you're trying
to Market and get business and so to me
there's so much more permission for
creativity Than People allow themselves
but you know like people continue to
like wear their suit and tie in their
LinkedIn profile and like they they they
don't understand the room is what I Al
ultimately think I think like you take
the most stuffed up person you know
literally I want everyone to close their
eyes and just think about like the most
kind of buttoned up stuffy rigid person
you know I promise you if that person
goes to Las Vegas right now with their
best friends from college for a weekend
they're going to be a different version
of themselves than you know them and I
think businesses and brands have more
permission to be contextual to the room
they're Distributing the content in when
I make Facebook content I'm thinking
about parents because I know the demo is
going to be older those are going to be
different videos that I'm putting into
Tik Tok where I know they're going to be
youngsters the words and the videos and
the slang and everything I say and do is
different yet I believe most people are
just making a video and then pushing
them out on these channels and expecting
for it to succeed they think of it as
distribution I think of it as a place
you have to be contextual to win the
room because it's a
conversation before it even gets into a
conversation you can't win when you're a
fish out of water as a communicator if
you don't know the room you will lose if
you go give a commencement speech to a
very conservative college and you sling
unlimited liberal propaganda it won't
land with those kids and vice versa if
you're a Jets fan like I am and you go
to Boston and you on the Patriots
the whole time you're going to lose some
people you've got to know the room and
you're raising capital from a VC firm
that is very buttoned up that's a
different presentation to an angel
investor who they were all entrepreneurs
and they built it themselves if you do
not know the
slang you will be out of place and so I
I believe before it becomes a
conversation my friend if you do not
know what the picture and video needs to
look like at 3:34 p.m. on a Monday in
LinkedIn which is mainly consumed by
people who are at work think about all
the psychology goes into this I'm
posting different content when I know
you're at work than when I'm posting on
the weekend and knowing you might be
skimming your LinkedIn real quick while
you're catching up on work or you're at
your kids baseball game and you're bored
and you're just looking at your LinkedIn
like I reverse engineer the
psychology of the room the psychology of
the person in the room at the time that
they consume the content that level of
thought besides thinking what the thumb
nail looks like besides thinking what
the first 3 seconds of the video has to
be to even keep you to consume it this
is a level of Science in day trading
attention that I believe 99% are not
executing on in Social and there in lies
the opportunity and the vulnerability
all right I want to ask you about
something else can I ask you about V
friends please I am fascinated by V
friends thank you this started at least
when I first saw it as like nft and then
Collectibles and toys and clothing and
now there was a Halloween float I saw
you were on TV on a Halloween float like
what what what is be friends is it like
is it a promotional vehicle is it like
the next Pokemon or Disney like much
more number two I um I'm loudly and
quietly trying to build Sesame Street
meets Pokemon and I say loudly and then
quietly when I first launched it nft
summer
all you know the Gary ve of how I do
things I brought awareness to it quietly
to your point when I'm building out a
Halloween parade float for New York
City's Halloween big bash I didn't
overly promote that in my channels I did
it because I knew hundreds of thousands
of people on the street were going to
see the float and we're going to hand
out chachis and cards and shirts and I
wanted to see organically what it was
going to do I'm working on YouTube kids
I have a kids book coming out next year
I believe I'm 47 soon to be
48 I believe that you and I benefited
from the content we consumed as a kid on
television not fully there was plenty of
silly stuff but even if you go back to
the 80s when gi. Joe did its cartoon it
had a message at the end when He-Man did
its cartoon it had a message at the end
Sesame Street I will tell you when I
started this I thought I was building
Disney now I know I'm building Sesame
Street why because as I've been on this
journey I don't think I understood or
gave enough credit credit and even
though I follow pop culture I'm
incredibly impressed and humbled by what
Jim Henson's agenda was I think he had
great intent fraggle rocks brief when
they tried to create it the brief was
stop War what greater Mission could you
have I as Gary Vee am a character I know
who I am but in all of my bravado and
competitiveness and loudness and cursing
and Jersey if for the ones that have
looked closer I'm really pushing empathy
and patience and kindness and there Nice
Guys Finish First and there is a way to
build a big Empire but doing it in a
kind way and we need more compassion and
real leaders don't yell at people they
they capture the stress and they treat
their people you build up people and you
play long and life should not be
transactional I want to win I like this
is why I say Pokemon meets Sesame Street
I also believe we've lost our way in
some of our warmth I think it is bad to
give kids eighth place trophies I don't
think it teaches them about life I think
we've over coddled kids we've created
entitlement I think I believe there's a
lot of anxiety I have thousands of under
25y old employees or under 30 I believe
a lot of them don't have enough
self-esteem because they've been overc
coddled because everything's been taken
care of themselves so using politics red
and blue v friends is purple I want to
teach the world about purple I think
that I think the competitive clown I
want to make him very famous and I want
people to care about him but he as a
character is going to teach kids like
winning and losing is good and like when
you lose you can learn from that and
like and by the way if you're seven and
you lose when you you cry when you lose
that's not bad it's actually good when
parents say what are you crying for this
doesn't matter for a seven-year-old
who's got wiring of being competitive
and ambitious I promise you it does
matter I promise you it matters and I
don't think we should eliminate that
from kids we you know and I think we
haven't found our equilibrium in modern
parenting so be friends is a
collectible storytelling platform that I
hope in 30 years will be uh in the
conversation with the Marvels and the
Pokemons and the Hello Kitties and the
Sesame Streets I want to build out these
characters accountable ant will teach
kids and parents that accountability
matters if you blame the school for your
kids' problems or social media for your
kids problems you're not setting them up
for success
you know patient Panda will teach people
that patience is how you actually win
everybody wants it now now now which
makes them shortcut which is why people
don't achieve what they actually are
capable of so what is be friends it's an
intellectual property and as as an
entrepreneur like you said at one point
you thought it was Disney now you think
it's it's Sesame like when when you
started this was it just nfts like did
you see the journey and how do the
journey even if you look at my earliest
content I knew nfts was a moment similar
to after school television I viewed the
nft summer don't forget I was making
videos that said 99% of nfts are going
to zero I knew what we were in which is
what web 1 was in in
9798 I knew the internet was going to be
big and the internet stocks and the
internet companies were overvalued by
short-term greed same with nfts but the
technology is real digital Collectibles
will be a part of everyone's life and
that's what be friends are they are
digital Collectibles but I also want
physical Collectibles the comic book the
trading cards it's a it's a 360 figal IP
fortnite is played as a video game
digitally but people buy fortnite
trading cards and fortnite comic books
and fortnite hats and I mean you know
Disney was digital if you really think
about it it was it wasn't really digital
but like when Disney came out those that
was a that was Cinema but you watched it
on TV Steamboat Willie on a screen later
in movie theaters and then television
but you bought physical items so for me
nft
hysteria a was an opportunity to create
the original
collectible you know it's really cool
like just like owning the first comic
book from Spider-Man vfriend series 1
nft is the original digital collectible
but now we're expanding it and I have a
real purpose behind why the characters
exist and it's to scale me I have done
well and have massed a nice audience
there's a lot of people that value me
but there's a lot of people that won't
consume me I don't fit the way I don't
look the part for them there are plenty
of people who don't like cursing I curse
when I communicate that eliminates me um
I'm very hyper some people like a calmer
Soul so my V friends characters my 250
plus v Friends character will allow me
to put more love and kindness and
accountability and hard work into the
world and that's my plan all right um I
don't know how much more time can I two
more minutes yeah yeah I well you you
mentioned the thousands of uh young
people who work for you there and I'm
curious about the cultural challenges of
being a scaled business yes I know
you've said like you don't want to be
corporate you know you are corporate
without employees and I guess like how
do you balance that and how does the
sort of in office and out of office like
work from Office impact that I know
that's a lot to oh there's a lot there
but I'll I'll bang it out um first of
all the way to not be corporate is not
to be corporate to your point I on vayer
for everybody Vayner media is a global
advertising agency think Mad Men for
2024 you know we have 400 people in Asia
3 400 people in Europe 100 people in
latam like this is a global ass company
this a big company we've been building
the way not to be corporate is not to be
corporate here's what I mean by that as
long as I continue to for example I sign
off on every firing in the entire
company globally there's not one person
in this company that can be fired
without me signing off because I'm
scared that my leaders will do politics
and corporate stuff not human stuff so
as a checks and balances I am literally
the singular human being that has to
sign off on any firing at Vayner media
not at Vayner X because there's eight
companies and there's other CEOs and I
give them that Latitude but at Vayner
media I'm the literally no one can be
let go and by the way 20% of the people
that everybody else wanted to let go is
not let go because I see something that
feels corporate so I think that's just
one of aund examples that you can you
don't have to be corporate if you make
weird family business decisions like I
do and I think it's more scalable than
people think it's you've got to find
your teammates around the office there's
a lot to it work from home is incredibly
challenging build building culture
remotely is impossible it's very hard we
do a lot on Virtual I as I sit here
today being completely vulnerable I do
not have all the answers we're still in
it I don't want to be the old man that
says walk home from I used to walk home
from school and like everybody to be in
the office 5 days a week when I see
plenty of wonderful things from work
from home the work life balance I like
that people are seeing their kids more
like I like a lot on the flip side it is
very clear to me that the employees
globally that are in the office are
advancing past the ones that are not
because they're winning on the biggest
thing in an office it's called osmosis
the osmosis you get from learning from
senior people who've done it things it's
profound and so I'm incredibly
challenged and led by this right now I'm
very worried about doing the wrong thing
by my employees who I'm not forcing to
come into the office when I'm watching
their reports eventually going to become
their managers because we're going to
grow on Merit and so it's a very
challenging time for a lot of us leaders
and figuring this out but I do believe
my intent is in a good place I believe
there are thousands of business owners
out there that truly have good intent
it's not some philosophical emotional
like I want everybody in the office or
the other way around and so as long as
I'm not delusionally emotional or
ideologically emotional the reason we
have not set a firm firm black and white
policy yet at Vayner X around work from
home is I'm still thinking and I'm still
watching and and but but yes it is very
hard to build community if everyone's
virtual because I I saw a video you did
recently where you were kind of teasing
a remote employee who was like I don't
feel more connected and you were kind of
like well that's the thing on a one
toone basis I give the answers to
employees and both directions uh
literally in the last couple weeks I've
had both sides of the pillow of the
conversation one employee saying to me
that they're stressed because they feel
like they're underd delivering as a
parent and I said take advantage of our
policy don't come to the office as much
and like pick up your kid at home and
don't SCH like I'm I believe I don't
need every like I want my employees to
be happy and so I don't need them to be
top performers I prefer it but you can't
be a top performer if you're not happy
and so if this woman who I'm thinking of
I pushed her very hard I'm like pick up
your kid from school it's okay like
don't do meetings from 4:15 to 4:30
you're such a crazy worker you're more
than making it up you're not ripping us
off like you're not ripping your team
off like do that and like in a week she
had a like she was thrilled and I was
like man just that subtle tweak and
obviously you saw that other piece of
content yeah when I'm sitting with an
employee on Zoom and they're complaining
that they feel disconnected and they've
never been in the office in their two
and a half years of working here I'm
like hey would have you and and it's not
like they're in Ohio the person that I
was referring to is literally 18 minutes
from the office and has never been here
I'm like of course you feel disconnected
that's not on me that's on you you know
and so this goes back to accountability
account um the world has become
infatuated with fingers we've become
incredibly good at telling everybody
what they're bad at and we are very bad
at thumbs we do not look at ourselves
and so yes this young man like we had a
nice conver and I said it nicely I was
like Hey brother I was like you're
feeling disconnected cuz you're in your
house by yourself all day like come in
the office a little bit like you got it
lucky there's people slepping an hour
and a half commuting here because they
want to feel connected you're 18 minutes
away on
foot like you know and so um and he took
that at heart and he sent me an email
and said I do feel it thank you for
saying that and like so you know it's
always it's back to purple yeah the
world is in fatuated with red and blue
in every way not just politically and
I'm trying to continue to Champion for
purple because I think that's where we
find our happiness I do think balance
matters even in eating Trends it's
complicated it's very complicated but
but being happy is worth fighting for
like when everyone's say God that's hard
I'm like it's worth fighting for
don't you don't don't you want to have
peace of mind aren't you tired of being
anxious isn't it enough of all the world
is selling fear brother like the world
is weaponizing fear and I think I think
for someone like me and for I'll end
with this cuz I'm running late I got to
run but thank you for having me on for
the people out there who are listening
who feel happy I mean it like genuinely
you're in a nice place please take it on
yourself as a responsibility to maybe
start posting a little bit more about
happiness I think the world is the
people who are most hurt and unhappy are
very
loud and I feel the happy are staying in
their inner circles and like just
letting their little family in circle be
happy I get a lot of ridicule a lot of
judg I deal with a lot of for being
loud and out there but I do feel a sense
of responsibility for um pushing
optimism practical optimism Happiness
joy because there's a lot of it in the
world as well and vs is how I'm going to
scale that and um I'm up for the
challenge